steve jobs and some of the life lessons
that the late great steve jobs
left
uh before he left four of them this
earth four lessons from the late great
steve jobs here are four lessons
from steve jobs so for those who don't
know
um
he died almost 10 years ago so this
october 5th
will be 10 years since he passed he died
october 5th
2011. so obviously created quite the
legacy
founder of apple steve jobs wozniak the
waz uh but steve jobs controversial
figure you've seen the movies didn't
make friends but created quite the
legacy
so here are four great
lessons from steve jobs
before his passing number one failure
equals
opportunity what does that mean failure
equals opportunity he says if you're
willing to recognize and embrace failure
it could become a tool
for success okay
basically don't let failure or haters
weigh you down you're not going to win
everything right
fall 10 times get up 11. 100. next
example of this starts with jobs failure
at higher education he went to school he
actually started at reed college in 1973
and then he dropped
dropped out but then he started to drop
in
on classes that he actually liked and
that were relevant
one was a calligraphy class of all
classes he loved the class and he said
that's the lessons that he learned in
that class were a major influence in the
design of mac computers what are the
odds drops out of school
and decides to drop in on this
calligraphy class
and somehow that is a motivating factor
in him designing
mac computers pretty gangster we're all
using iphones these days and if he
didn't you know drop in on that
calligraphy class in 1973 in reed
college who knows what happened so you
don't have to take every single thing
from every single course you can pick
the ones that you can take some
takeaways from so one of the things like
i obviously i went uh we all you know we
we went to college here the one class
that i remember taking in college i took
a listening
class a listening class what are the
odds of that but it taught you how to
listen so a lot of people these days
they just want to wait their turn to
speak all right you're done talking i
can talk now
but as they say you've got two ears in
one mouth for a reason you don't listen
to see what talks next
for you to talk next you listen to
actually hear what the other person's
saying so i understand where he's
getting um i like giving that advice
okay number two from steve jobs keep
faith through
adversity
what does he mean he says sometimes life
hits you in the head with a brick but
you should not lose faith you don't
often hear the word faith when it comes
to business right
the truth is that sometimes times are
tough
times are tough and faith is critical do
you believe in yourself do you believe
in what you're doing or you're just kind
of like
i don't know man i don't have a i don't
know if this is going to work but i
believe in what i'm doing that's faith
it can mean the difference between
survival or disintegrating right so in
money
one of the things i have faith in is the
stock market i don't think the stock
market is going to crash and go to zero
i said i talk about
not timing the market time in the market
i believe in compound interest and even
when the markets are going badly you
weather the storm and uh think in the
long term so that's my little
perspective what's that noise by the way
david stop playing with him
okay
number three from steve jobs what makes
a successful life he says uh your time
is limited so don't waste it living
someone else's life that's very powerful
right there don't be trapped by dogma
which is living with the results of
other people's thinkings other people's
thinkings we talked about boomers and
millennials different mentalities
different way of thinking maybe the old
guard
is
telling you to do things that worked for
them
but that might not necessarily work for
you we'll get we'll follow up on that in
a second
um
have the courage to follow your heart
and your intuition this is steve jobs
here guys
um
follow that gut instinct because only
you
have yourself
so please don't let the noise get to
your head okay cool thank you steve jobs
and number four
stay foolish
what does that mean stay foolish one of
the most powerful quotes associated with
steve jobs is stay hungry stay foolish
staying hungry is easy to interpret yo
bro work hard stay hungry you got to
keep it moving you got to innovate you
got to discover new things you got to
progress cool doesn't happen you know
overnight stay hungry stay hungry cool
but staying foolish is a little bit
a little trickier what does that mean
nobody wants
to be foolish right
so but it's not foolish in the
conventional sense but basically
foolishness is a willingness to take on
risks
foolish to to basically say
look even when others are telling us not
to do something
i i'm gonna give it a go i don't know i
believe in this right kind of like what
number three he said
um
faith through adversity
um
so
being foolish might call you a visionary
when i met pat
he had this foolish idea of not
recruiting people with a life insurance
license he said if you've been in the
business i didn't want to deal with you
i just want to
carve my own blue ocean strategy and
train people recruit train teach
and build their businesses up because
the guys created a multi multi 100
million dollar
business so if you never take the risk
you'll always be thinking what if so
those are some awesome advice
from
steve jobs
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sauce cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay bro